kate middleton
is surprising people all over london
i really hope i can i can make a
difference you know even
in the smallest way to mark the release
of her new photography book
hold still a portrait of our nation in
2020
the duchess of cambridge found a very
special way of sharing it with the
community in a video posted to the duke
and duchess of cambridge instagram
account
kate rocking a stunning long red coat
hides copies of her book on the grounds
of kensington palace
the caption explains quote let the
search begin
each copy is adorned with a gold book
fairy sticker
gold ribbon and has a letter from the
duchess tucked inside
kate linked up with the organization
book fairies which is a literary
movement that urges readers to share
books that they have read and enjoyed
by leaving them in public places for
others to find
the duchess's book features 100
portraits reflecting the many different
faces of individual experiences
as the coven 19 pandemic took hold
adding to kate's busy day she also
visited the royal london hospital
and the national portrait gallery a year
to the day since she launched the
hold still photography project with the
gallery
at the time the duchess invited people
of all ages from across the uk
to submit a photographic portrait that
they took during the first
lockdown and over the last year kate has
spoken to many of the 100 hold still
finalists
and on thursday kensington palace shared
one of those phone calls
on kate and prince william's new youtube
channel
good morning royal highlands good
morning my goodness me you're super
light mila
that's kate speaking to four-year-old
mila who's battling leukemia
about her photo called shielding mila
showing her waving to her dad
from the other side of the window do you
want to tell me about your daddy how
come you couldn't see him for so long
because he had to look after me because
i went for a treatment
yeah and was it really hard not seeing
him
yeah when he came into the house
i was like so surprised kate also talked
to mila about her three children
george charlotte and louie and after
learning mila's favorite color is
pink the duchess made mila a special
promise
what's your favorite color
pink okay well i have to make sure i
have to make sure i again try and find
myself a pink dress
okay that hopefully when one day
hopefully me will get to meet
and then i'll remember to wear my pink
dress fee yay